on va continuer à parler à de ces Jeux
Olympiques pour ça on va aller voir
Jacques paquet bonjour Jacques merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteur en
chef du journal du Grand Paris on va
parler des JO mais sous un autre angle
puisque des questions se posent sur la
sécurité de ces Jeux Olympiques
absolument bonjour monsieur le sénateur
vous avez rendu en juillet dernier je
crois un rapport sur le la finale de la
Ligue des champions au Stade de France
qui s'était déroulé le 28 mai 2022 et on
se souvient avec un certain nombre
d'échauffes fourrés vous et vous
écriviez que ces événements avaient
gravement interrogé je vous cite la
capacité de la France à organiser les
grands événements sportifs alors là on
va
je crois est-ce que vous êtes serein
vous faisiez une quinzaine de
préconisations à vous listiez série de
dysfonctionnement vous dire on peut pas
tout mettre sur la responsabilité des
supporters de Liverpool comme certains
l'ont fait est-ce que Monsieur Laffont
vous estimez que vous avez été écouté
vous vous préconisez la meilleure
formation des stadiers une meilleure
communication entre les équipes plus de
souplesse on vous donne des signes pour
vous dire que on vous a écouté et que
tout va bien se passer pour les JO
notamment pour la série cérémonie
d'ouverture qui est inédite
la finale de la Champions League je
crois que ça a été une véritable prise
de conscience et d'une certaine manière
il y avait une forme de certitude des
autorités françaises de dire ce type
d'événement on les a déjà organisés on
sait les organiser voilà une forme de
certitude et peut-être d'arrogance dans
le comportement de certains responsables
le fait que ça ait dysfonctionné et ça a
dysfonctionnait à tous les étages de du
fonctionnement des des autorités
responsables à ce moment-là a été une
vraie prise de conscience que malgré
notre savoir-faire on pouvait aussi
faire des erreurs
cet événement était un événement
malheureux évidemment nous le regrettons
tous mais d'une certaine manière ça a
été un an un peu plus de deux ans avant
les Jeux Olympiques un événement qui a
permis de mobiliser chacun et de
reprendre en main tous les systèmes de
de contrôle alors est-ce que on est pour
autant totalement rassuré nous on nous
restons vigilants en tant que les Jeux
Olympiques n'ont pas eu lieu on peut pas
dire
auparavant ce que ça va bien se passer
je pense que l'élément phare évidemment
des futurs jeux c'est cette cérémonie
d'ouverture qui peut être un très bel
événement moi j'en suis persuadé l'idée
de le faire sur la scène et une belle
idée qui mettra en valeur la France
Paris les grands monuments le long de la
Seine qui sera très proportionné qui est
pas risqué c'est dans notre tradition
française on se souvient les Jeux
Olympiques d'Albertville on se souvient
de cette cérémonie d'inauguration qui a
quelque part un peu bouleversé les
cérémonies d'inauguration donc je pense
que qu'on ait cette ambition là pour
ceux de Paris est une belle et bonne
ambition après on voit bien qu'il y a
encore certains arbitrages qui doivent
être rendus notamment sur la jauge
400500.000 600 000 sur la façon de de
filtrer les les spectateurs qui qui
viendront je pense qu'il faut trouver le
bon équilibre entre l'ambition de cette
cérémonie d'ouverture et la nécessité
d'assurer la sécurité
sur un parcours qui est complexe on le
sait mais la nécessité d'assurer la
sécurité quelque part je le souhaite en
tout cas que ça soit qu'un mauvais
événement
servent de de d'une belle et une manière
quelque part la finale de la Champions
League l'année dernière a été la semaine
point mal pour un bien voilà absolument
vous avez l'impression que la France est
prête à accueillir ces Jeux Olympiques
nous le verrons l'été 2024 j'ai le
sentiment et notamment depuis un an
qu'elle se donne tous les moyens pour y
parvenir nous nous avons alerté
effectivement à travers le rapport que
nous avions fait avec le président de la
que j'avais fait avec le président de la
commission des lois
mon collègue buffet sur un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements nous avons
été entendu sur pas mal de points il me
semble qu'il y a toujours un élément
d'incertitude qui est sur la capacité de
des sociétés de gardiennage privée à
assurer en nombre la sécurité sur
l'ensemble des sites olympiques mais
aussi sur le reste du territoire
national le recours à larmée me paraît
incontournable je pense que à un moment
il faudra que l'État soit clair sur ce
cette élément là pour l'instant il reste
un peu ambigu
Jacques on change totalement de sujet
Laurent Laffont le Val-de-Marne que vous
représentez au Sénat est réputé pour
avoir été un pionnier du du Grand Paris
Express réseau qui va bientôt voir le
jour avec les premières lignes qui sont
annoncées pour dans quelques mois et il
se trouve que on vient de d'apprendre il
y a une proposition de loi à l'Assemblée
nationale qui va dans ce sens qu'on va
étendre ces missions et qu'on va lui
confier la coordination de ce qu'on
appelle leur trivialement les réseaux de
RER métropolitain et plus
administrativement des services express
régionaux métropolitain
est-ce que vous considérez que c'est une
bonne idée monsieur le sénateur ou
est-ce que vous y voyez le risque qu'on
dévoie cette société de ces missions et
éventuellement on est l'idée de puiser
dans ces caisses
sur les conditions financières il faudra
regarder de près effectivement je trouve
que c'est une idée intéressante qui
mérite d'être gardée parce que d'abord
la SGP fait son travail même si les
réseaux n'est pas encore terminé et mis
en circulation le sentiment que ça donne
c'est qu'elle fait bien son travail donc
il y a un vrai savoir-faire qui a été
concentré à l'intérieur de cette SGP
encore une fois on réalise près 200 km
de de de réseau en quelques années dans
un contexte urbain compliqué tout le
monde ne peut pas se permettre de faire
ça et ne sait pas faire ça donc
l'idée de dire que ce savoir-faire la
qualité de ses équipes puissent servir
au-delà de la livraison du Grand Paris
Express je crois est une idée
intéressante c'est l'objet de cette
proposition de loi nous allons la
regarder avec beaucoup d'attention comme
ça personnellement je suis plutôt ouvert
à cette idée
il y a pas de risque vous êtes un expert
vous êtes un expert en finance publique
monsieur Lafont vous n'y voyez pas un
risque qu'on vienne taper dans la caisse
si vous pouvez m'exprimer m'excuser
cette expression triviale il faudra
regarder de près parce que le
financement du Grand Paris Express comme
vous le savez bien puisque vous aussi
vous le suivez depuis de nombreuses
années c'est des recettes franciliennes
qui servent à financer
cette nouvelle ligne de métro et puis
c'est surtout un emprunt qui va
essentiellement financer en train qui va
être remboursé pendant de nombreuses
années il va falloir bien arriver à
scinder et à clairement identifier ce
qui relève du Grand Paris Express et de
ce qui pourrait être les autres missions
les autres chantiers de cette Société du
Grand Paris sur le papier comme ça cette
scission et cette cette organisation
nouvelle ne me paraît pas impossible
après il faut voir comment ça se traduit
merci merci d'avoir été avec nous à la
Une du journal du Grand Paris c'est le
patron de la banque des territoires qui
dresse un bilan de son institution
c'est-à-dire dans le journal du Grand
Paris merci Jacques d'avoir été avec
nous à très vite
[Musique]